I'm joined today by Bill goldsmith who's
professor emeritus of city and regional
planning at Cornell University and also
the author of saving our cities a
progressive plan to transform urban
America bill it's so great to talk to
you and you know during the presidential
election between Donald Trump and
Hillary Clinton
we saw cities and urban centers referred
to in a lot of different ways it was
highly racialized in particular the way
that Donald Trump referred to big cities
and urban areas and there was also a lot
of discussion around cities with
relation to poverty so let's first take
the broadest step back that we can when
the discussion of cities become this
racialized good question great question
so let me bring it in two parts
when did the discussion become
racialized but maybe before that when
did cities become so remarkably
racialized we go back 40 or 50 or even
60 years to the post-world War two ERA
we discover that during the vast
suburbanization that created our
metropolitan areas federal policy
actually legally officially in effect
prohibited the mixing of races in areas
that received federal housing subsidies
bank loan guarantees through the Federal
Housing Administration this was a
uniformly - throughout the United States
it was prohibited finally by the Supreme
Court in the 1950s and it also
influenced totally housing policy for
public housing so was for private
suburban development and public housing
policy private suburban development was
restricted almost entirely to white
populations and housing policy located
black and poor and Latino and other
minority populations Chinese in San
Francisco for example in specific
housing projects restricted to them
alone so federal and local policy really
dictated
sharp shot segregation of races the
United States then during the Kennedy
and Johnson presidencies with lots and
lots of urban program there were
attempts to break this down but they
succeeded very little against massive
white flight so what we get by the time
we enter the election process this year
is a country that's just deeply deeply
divided between essentially dark-skinned
cities and poor cities cities with poor
inhabitants despite spikes of tremendous
wealth and places like Manhattan or a
central Seattle or Portland or San
Francisco
and suburbs that are largely white and
middle-class now it's true that by now a
majority of poor people by census
standards live in what we call suburbs
that is areas outside what some call the
white noose that strangles cities but
those are also often known as cities or
urban areas in our language and they're
deprived so they have inferior schools
inferior public services lower tax
incomes even though they have very very
high tax rates so this this sort of
stratification gets to be recognized as
Trump I think quite vulgar Lee refers to
all black people as though they're all
poor even though very very large numbers
of middle class and live in middle-class
suburbs and along those lines bill
because there's there's a you've touched
on something which was sort of going to
be what I wanted to get into next
there's this assumption often that
cities are the root of many of society's
problems in terms of being associated
with very high crime rates and drug
issues etc can you talk to us a little
bit about how we should really think
about that and one thing that seems
missing to me from
that conversation is by their very
nature when you have higher
concentrations of people you are going
to have dynamics that are different than
in rural and suburban areas and I don't
feel like that's often accounted for
when cities are just criticized yeah
well you're right and you seen what I've
written so you know I agree the the the
so there's a couple of issues here first
of all it's not at all clear that City
crime rates are higher than rural crime
rates and it is absolutely untrue that
rates of drug use in cities are higher
than rates of drug use in either suburbs
or small towns or rural areas there is
simply no evidence whatsoever and there
are massive surveys undertaken every
year by good solid statistical agencies
University of Michigan Survey Research
Center for example working for the Drug
Enforcement Agency and the census and so
forth that show that drug use rates are
pretty uniform across racial groups
they're somewhat lower among Asians
they're somewhat higher among Native
American Indians but the two three big
groups that are always examined blacks
whites Hispanics or Latinos the the drug
alcohol tobacco uses very up and down a
little bit across his not very much
similarly they don't vary much by a
location what does vary is where police
can find as you suggest here relatively
dense concentrations of people where
it's much easier to make large numbers
of arrests or for that matter it may be
easier to find locations where drugs are
sold
of course when they're sold they're sold
by city residents to people who come in
from the suburbs to buy them I mean
that's where the money is the big money
is of course in selling drugs to people
who have lots of money and that's
predominantly in the United States
whites so the drug problem is
principally a white problem that
were though which does as all evidence
suggests nothing whatsoever to reduce to
either drug sales or drug use prosecutes
people who happen to live in poor
neighborhoods of central cities the
reasons for that are very complex they
have to do with ideology with racism
with this sort of theme that drug
problems are always someone else's
problems unlike alcohol problems where
everybody has an Uncle Louie who's an
alcoholic and it's a problem at family
gatherings and weddings and so forth and
we sort of treat them as though it's a
behavioral problem a mental problem
something to be tolerated but controlled
whereas with minority drug use we say
these are criminals they're thugs
they're people ruining our world it's
simply not true but it's just it's been
worked into our ideology so thoroughly
this begins a long long time ago with
Asian exclusion laws with the assumption
that drug abuse in cities was something
brought in by the Chinese and then
attempts to export Mexicans very early
on who are accused of bringing marijuana
into the country this is I'm talking
about 4050 years ago even longer and
then of course the blame entirely that
the whole drug problem is a problem of
ghettos in American cities when it isn't
at all the problem is that the drug war
creates tremendous violence reduces
opportunities removes potentially
productive men from their homes and in
prison ISM in what is now widely
recognized as insanely large numbers of
people who haven't committed violent
crimes but go to prison and learn how to
commit violent crimes I'm myself
involved in a prison education program
that a group of Cornell professor
started running in the 1990s when the
Congress
and President Clinton cut funding for
college scholarships Pell grants to
prisons 1993 they just jumped in to
begin teaching in prisons and the
results have been absolutely phenomenal
we now work in for upstate New York
bad news prisons where prisoners are
just dying to get in and come to class
study hard that people who teach in the
prison simply love teaching there
because the prisoners are so responsive
and study so hard it's true they don't
have a lot else to do but it just
changes the tone sometimes in the entire
prison so so I'm combining all of this
putting the drug war or or the prison
expansion the enormous profits by
private corporations that supply prisons
a huge influx of sort of warfighting
material into police departments all the
fancy equipment and vehicles they have
the new kinds of crowd dispersal bombs
these flash bombs
ya know in the interest of because we
just have a limited time and there were
so many things I wanted to get to and
I'll have to sort of pick and choose
what we'll have time for you started to
get into the economic aspect of this in
the book you actually talked more about
the importance of inequality in cities
than just poverty itself an inequality
of course more of a relative measure
than poverty make that case why is
inequality something that we should be
looking closely at in relation to
poverty well you know that's that's
actually a great question I'm
remembering that in 1930 Justice
Brandeis said we can have democracy or
we can have an equality but we can't
have both those aren't his exact words
but it's very close in the last 20 years
as we all know because of the wall
street 1% protests we have funded
through our tax policies and our
expenditure policies a tiny minority
1/10 of 1% of the population
maybe and
very very giant corporations who have
just walked away with all of the
productivity gains in the last 20 or 30
years and they've taken money away from
just those people who I suspect in large
numbers voted for Donald Trump yesterday
that inequality comes on top of the
poverty for people at the bottom they're
not directly related but they're very
closely related I think it the
inequality in our cities which shows up
in the statistics but it's inequality
nationally as well
drives politics that leads us to ignore
the needs of the bulk of the population
this is the sort of lower ends of the
working-class and those who don't vote
at all who are lots of very poor people
all over the country and they're
predominantly concentrated in in cities
you know the the if you look at the
numbers something like eighty percent of
the US population lives in metropolitan
areas with populations larger than
200,000 people right so this this claim
that everybody's out in the rural areas
just isn't true large majorities of
Americans live either in cities or in
the suburbs immediately surrounding
cities they may have been small towns
before but they're really urbanized now
so this inequality leads us to ignore
the needs of large numbers of our
population and make things okay for
those of us who are lucky enough to have
good incomes and really okay for that
tiny group of people who have enormous
lehigh incomes and it's pretty clear to
me that that's a major piece of what's
driving on sort of insane politics today
yeah I think you're absolutely right
about that we've been speaking about the
book saving our cities a progressive
plan to transform urban America will be
very important over the next four years
under president elect Trump we've been
speaking with the books author Bill
Goldsmith thanks so much for talking to
us
about this thank you very much I enjoyed
talking to you